[Música]
economía en directo américa de france 24
ya me acompaña en el estudio daniel
hablando en esta mañana de miércoles
dani me encanta estar con usted porque
más inteligente se guapísima como en esa
camisa blanca
danny hablemos entonces de europa porque
ya se encienden las alarmas además lo
hablábamos ayer con nuestro invitado del
día por la posible falta de gas esto por
supuesto derivado de la guerra claro
raúl buenos días pues mire declaró una
alerta temprana esto es el primero de
tres pasos cuya fase más grave sería una
emergencia de suministro que obligaría a
cortar el gas natural para la industria
y proteger el consumo de los hogares o
priorizar lo lo que está haciendo
alemana y raúl es prepararse ante una
posible interrupción desde rusia desde
donde importa más de la mitad de este
hidrocarburo y la razón tiene que ver
con que moscú se alista para presentar
el jueves un plan de pagos en rublos y
no en dólares o en euros de su
combustible algo que ya lo hemos hablado
occidente ha rechazado por completo y
que traería consecuencias directas para
los consumidores que ya venían
afrontando precios altos
desde antes de la guerra
y función detuviera sus entregas de gas
y petróleo podríamos manejarlo
nuevamente aún no lo ha hecho y solo
estamos observando esto a nivel formal
más de cerca que antes nos hemos
preparado para esto a nivel personal y
también a nivel político para responder
pero obviamente habrá consecuencias como
precios altos o ciertas restricciones
estamos en una situación en la que cada
kilovatio hora de energía ahorrado ayuda
y es por eso que también quiero usar
esta declaración de alerta temprana para
hacer un llamado a los industriales y
consumidores privados para que nos
ayuden ahorrando gas y energía en
general vamos a ver entonces qué pasa
con alemania ni pero polonia y así dar
los primeros pasos entonces para cortar
los los lazos energéticos con rusia no
claro y planea imponer el primero que
todo un embargo a las importaciones de
carbón ruso a partir de mayo próximo
también dejará de usar petróleo desde
ese país desde finales de 2022 y aunque
quiere que el resto de países haga lo
mismo pues los demás saben que no pueden
dejar de comprar de un día para otro
porque dependen de este suministro así
que lo harán poco a poco es obvia
también pidió un impuesto a los
hidrocarburos pero pues hay que esperar
que dice la unión europea sobre esto que
no vamos a ver qué va a pasar entonces
dani y yo como no soy tan bueno con los
números le pregunto por qué entonces
tanta polémica por esta exigencia de
rusia de pagar en rublos en que afecta
digamos el mercado de la parte que
paguen que afecta a rusia por favor
danos luz flórez pues mire raúl el
kremlin lo que ha dicho es que este
jueves va a expedir una regulación con
la que pretende que quienes quieran
comprarle a sus productos energéticos lo
hagan en rublos y hasta buscaría
extenderlo a otros productos como
insumos agropecuarios o los mismos
alimentos que también vende bastante
pero eso raúl complicaría a sus clientes
principalmente europeos porque tienen
una gran dependencia de rusia y hoy
pagan el 60 por ciento de los
hidrocarburos en euros o en dólares
ellos dicen que la medida viola los
contratos ya establecidos qué quiere
decir entonces que pagan en rublos pues
que los importadores tendrían que
encontrar un banco que les cambiara
euros o dólares por rublos y eso podría
ser bastante engorroso porque algunos
bancos rusos han sido bloqueados o
eliminados del sistema swift de pagos
internacionales aunque todavía quedan
algunos que dicen los analistas pues que
el hecho de que a rusia se le paguen
rubios en rublos podría eludir un poco
los castigos occidentales porque
tendrían que mantener esos bancos sin
sancionar pero también podría subir un
poco el valor del rublo que ha tocado
mínimos porque va a aumentar la demanda
de todas maneras raúl eso es mucho más
complicado porque a un importador pues
le conviene pagar en rublos que no valen
casi nada ahora pero lo difícil es
conseguirlos claro ahí está ahí está el
problema no tanto de plata sino donde se
consigue extraño y menos mal que usted y
yo no somos fanáticos de las cripto
monedas porque ocurrió el segundo robo
de tritones más grande de la historia
por eso siempre hacemos énfasis en que
son de todas maneras unas plataformas
que no están no están vigiladas por las
autoridades y que nadie la respalda
porque se le robaron ese puesto donde
reclama a donde reclama pues piratas
informáticos lograron acceder a las
claves privadas de para lograr robar 540
millones de dólares en fondos
criptográficos de una plataforma
conocida como block change broner ahora
los usuarios no pueden retirar o
depositar fondos en esta red que
promueve el popular juego en línea axa e
infiniti yo no lo conozco pero dicen que
es muy popular los hackers han apuntado
por mucho tiempo a las plataformas
criptográficas el the block change
robben a un solo ha sido superado en
montón por el robo de paul y networking
de unos 610 millones de dólares en
agosto del año pasado del que también
hablamos aunque dicen que gran parte del
dinero fue recuperado también ha habido
otros como wormhole o con check con
grandes sumas involucradas cómo
funcionan estos cripto tivo son y pues
en el caso del videojuego que estábamos
hablando son videojuegos que se basan en
activos digitales que se transan en
plataformas de tecnología block change
que son las mismas que se usan con las
cripto monedas en el caso de la calle
infinita el usuario lucha contra
criaturas llamadas access axa es que se
digitalizan como tokens y qué pues son
canjeables por dinero y se estima que es
la mayor colección de esta clase de
cripto activos de todos los tiempos
bueno danny y empezó con deuda este
miércoles nos debe los indicadores
económicos y la cifra al día para
nuestro segundo bloque de economía
porque ya llegó el tiempo de presentar
nuestro reportaje mucha información